he said what a cheater you're a cheater
daniel jesus i cheated but you pushed me
to that
[Music]
hi hello who are you and how do you know
each other i'm daniel my name is
mackenzie and we used to date used to
what does that mean we're on a break
you broke up
you broke up
it's okay it's not because something is
uh
broken that you can't fix it you
understand
you broke up we're on a break no you're
done you're gonna see a whole lot of
tension two [ __ ] on a break it
just means that they're gonna be pissed
off if you're gonna see someone else
there's gonna be tension
who proposed being on a break i feel
like that was me i disagree you broke up
with me but i said we should be on a
break
wow
they can't even agree on who
girl
are you
in separate places you live together
separate places we were living together
and then i found out some stuff i'm not
gonna lie i look at this girl's head and
she feels like she should be a cast
member on loving basketball the gay
edition yeah
no just loving basketball
it's just something about the hair and
the whole look the loose t-shirt yeah
the [ __ ] gold chain yeah the scream's
like hey [ __ ] i got a couple strap-ons
she did the ones that lift my mind the
one thing i didn't want her to do in
high school she dated my best friend my
best guy friend and then they broke up
and then we got together obviously for
the past couple years now i found out
that they had like got together and
that's like the worst thing for me is
like going back to an ex i feel like is
a big deal you went to breakup with her
and you mad she went back with the next
wait hold on wait what the [ __ ]
bring it back
she was dating him before
then y'all got together and now you
actually went to go take the x
[ __ ] so we on a break
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no we in a hot mess
this is bp oil spill the oceans the
birds are dying yeah
what happened to that girl
no what's killing me what's killing is
that she mad that her girl did
what
she did to her friend no ye no
he was dating the white girl no yeah
okay
they break up yeah
she slides in
with her best friend's ex
you understand i see what you're saying
okay because because the thing is
because that's not a problem to me but
take yourself out of it
yeah
she went with her best friend's ex yeah
they date for multiple years they break
up
and she went back to him and now she's
mad she's mad because she did yeah i see
what you're saying i see what you're
saying i see what you're saying
you you can all the way be [ __ ] up now
yes cause that's a bill the deal breaker
did what i do yeah i see what you're
saying get yourself out of there eric
yeah listen i don't know this guy is i
don't know
why you friends are dating these people
this whatever
that's a whole last mess square triangle
you guys are involved in this bermuda
nonsense those are a lot of faces who do
you think is having the harder time with
this break near you me
yeah she looks all the way crazy i'm not
gonna lie yeah that's a dead that's
she look
she said me with her entire body me she
engaged her core muscles flexed her
biceps got her traps involved and went
me
is the pink hair what we still live
together even in separate rooms i don't
want to think about you bringing
somebody
into a place that we got together i
personally wouldn't be able to do that
that's why for me like on a break or on
an open relationship or whatever i can't
talk to someone like you talk to people
i can't do you want an open relationship
is that what you're i want the open
relationship and it's but it's like
we're not trying to mess with other
people it's like she's all into what i'm
doing no no no no no in an open
relationship my definition of that and
we made the rules is you go have sex
with other people you don't build
she's subjected to oh it looked like
that's what you want not what you agreed
you said that and that's what you wanted
now a real open relationship is really
much more complex than whatever the [ __ ]
you think it is my definition a is a
definition it's what it's your
parameters which is parameters permit
whatever it's your boundaries within
that relationship and that's fine but an
open relationship needs to be more than
that and those boundaries need to be
clear now if you don't want him to build
a relationship that's fine but you and
if he wants to build a relationship
that's also fine but if you don't agree
with that you should get the [ __ ] out of
there because that's not your place my
dude my dude
she gave you the keys to the kingdom and
you still want more yeah she said you
wanna go get some side [ __ ] go ahead
still be building up [ __ ] whole ass
relationships with these [ __ ] yeah
but and you out here talking about i
want to look
stupid but you know what else i might
have called her crazy but she sounded
more coherent and consistent than you no
but so that means that you shady that
means that you shady the thing that
happened is that it's not so much that
it's shady it's really just the
parameters of what parameters of what
the relationship is or not the same and
and and they just went on that that's
what it is so if you're act
hold on if you actually
agreed on not building anything with
other [ __ ] then if it's
actually true that you actually believe
that then yeah dude you're [ __ ] wrong
for that she sounds less crazy than him
just with that statement that she did
but other than that they both crazy well
i mean i could imagine that if i agree
to something in a relationship and i
find out you're doing the opposite that
might drive me cut nuts and yes you
still stay there
sure there might be some level
insecurity there but i'm saying he's the
one who's driving her there i mean he's
the one who betrayed the relationship
that's the equivalent of like i agree me
be in a relationship with a girl i cheat
on her and then she starts acting
irrational and crazy and getting upset
i'm like well i pushed her there
and i feel like we are like our souls
are connected if we end up breaking up
is there someone you have in mind as
your next partner
um
hold up
wait a minute no wasn't this loving
basketball [ __ ] just talking about we
are soul mates like our souls are
supposed to be intertwined
and she already got the replacement
lined up no but that's just the soul the
[ __ ] can do whatever the [ __ ] please
you you you answered the question yeah
you have somebody else lined up i can't
answer the only reason you can't answer
is because the answer is yes do you have
someone in mind or actually how many
people have you told that you want to be
with them okay you got to understand
that you see me texting someone saying
like i want to be with them it's not
like i want to
be with him you are a cheater
no way those words came out this
motherfucker's mouth
there's no way
there's no way those words came out this
motherfucker's mouth with a straight
face
and she said you are a cheater
damn right lady hey listen pick hair
i'm with you apologize for calling you
crazy earlier yay
you with a shifty ass [ __ ] move
on
but that's dirty
i told you i hate this [ __ ] i
can understand that you're aggravated
now and you know what he got that
fuckboy haircut too he got that stupid
little mushroom top
that lebron originally i got the
mushroom shark
yeah
literally i see that yeah but it's
different than having a mushroom i like
psychedelics i know you do you told me
about that i like psychedelics he uh
he's a trip for real for real
he said what a cheater you're a cheater
or daniel jesus i cheated but you pushed
me to that
[Music]
let's finish this
[Music]
hey you know what you're a wizard habba
you called it [ __ ] boy you said what he
said she really said that oh my god
oh my god
this man is dead food if you know what
if you if you if you cheat it's not
nobody puts you
you push your dick in that [ __ ] that's
the only person that it was this is a
sickness and it is deviant therefore you
don't want it i genuinely think that we
are like soul tied humans i think you
like understand me more than anybody
ever why we should stay together
because we're gonna have the most
beautiful children you'll ever see okay
you're crazy you're crazy you're back to
crazy
you're back to crazy you're back back
right back about you were doing good and
then whoop
right back you see just your instinct
oh you're dead inside and you killed
abba that's what you did the craziness
killed abba and i said crazy and i felt
it i was like oh yeah when you said that
oh there's a lot of undertones in that
[ __ ] that sounds weird like you know
what i mean it's all weird yeah
got flashbacks of people i know that act
like that and
um
have you fallen out of love with me
have you fallen out of love with me i
don't think i could i tried i tried too
i was so mad at you i'm petrified of
except with your ex i've always been you
know what i mean so i think that it's
just going to take me like calming down
just a little you're done stop you're
done you're done you're [ __ ] done
this [ __ ] kills you right there you're
brain dead and that's the only video
that we're gonna do for now cause you're
dead she killed you she [ __ ] killed
you the minute she said that you went
brain dead right now you're staring in
the nothingness and that's what it is
yeah all right uh there's not much
insight uh in that video except the fact
that if you decide to take a break
usually uh it's a bad idea all right
break it off or work it out or
just don't uh
for the person that was crazy it's
[ __ ] crazy we're gonna have them
crazy counseling
mental health um
that's pretty much it i don't have much
to say about that wasn't entertaining it
was exactly what the [ __ ] i thought it
was and it is what it is tell us what
you think would you would you break
would you break up with the ass you or
would you just take a break or you the
break take a break type or the break it
or work it out let us know right that's
all for today
anything to say
didn't think so all right
yeah buddy
go you have to
go take a nap
you're done you're you're
oh [ __ ]
all right
all right
see you later buddy
you